Transcription: Barbara Barbier
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir.
Vous voyez cette pierre ?
Avec cette pierre,
je peux faire plein de choses.
Je peux jouer avec.
Je peux casser des choses.
Je peux la lancer même.
Je peux détruire.
Ou alors, je peux construire.
Je peux construire une maison,
je peux même construire une cathédrale.
Le numérique, c'est un peu
comme cette pierre :
c'est un outil.
Avec lui, je peux choisir de détruire
ou bien de construire.
Moi, je crois que le numérique
peux nous aider à construire
une nouvelle forme de démocratie.
C'est ce qu'on a fait ici
au plan local à Toulouse,
avec une démarche d'innovation ouverte,
citoyens et smart city.
La smart city, c'est quoi ?
D'abord, smart, ça veut dire quoi ?
On dit que ça veut dire intelligent.
En Chine, on a construit une smart city.
Elle est super belle,
elle est grande avec de grands buildings,
tout brillants, plein de miroirs,
c'est ultra connectée, c'est très moderne.
C'est une vraie image de science-fiction.
Seulement, quand on la regarde de près,
on s'aperçoit qu'il manque quelque chose.
En fait, il n'y a personne dedans.
Cette ville, on l'a construite, d'abord,
et puis on mettra les gens dedans, après.
En fait, si on écoute les grandes firmes,
avec la smart city,
finalement la ville,
c'est une ville techno-centrée.
Moi, je crois que l'intelligence,
ce n'est pas ça.
L'intelligence,
c'est concevoir la ville de demain
avec les gens qui y vivent
aujourd'hui et qui y vivront.
Avec l'aide d'experts,
d'acteurs publics et d'acteurs privés.
C'est ce qu'on a fait, ici à Toulouse,
avec une grande démarche
d'intelligence collective.
Vous savez ce que c'est
l'intelligence collective ?
Vous savez ce que c'est ?
Vous en avez entendu parler ?
En fait, c'est un peu
comme une cathédrale.
Pas comme une cathédrale,
comme une chorale -
j'y suis déjà là, à ma cathédrale.
C'est comme une chorale, en fait.
On a des chanteurs
et puis, on a un chef de chœur.
Si le chef de chœur est bon,
à un moment donné,
au-dessus de la voix des chanteurs,
on va entendre une autre voix.
Une voix qui est au-dessus,
ce n'est pas la voix des chanteurs.
C'est une voix qui est puissante,
qui est vibrante,
qui vous prend les tripes.
On l'appelle : « la voix de l'ange ».
Une voix plus une voix égalent trois voix.
En fait, la troisième voix,
c'est celle du groupe.
L'intelligence collective,
c'est un peu pareil.
Une intelligence plus une intelligence
égalent trois intelligences.
Quand on fait travailler
les gens ensemble,
il y a une troisième intelligence
qui est celle du groupe.
Concrètement, comment ça se passe ?
En fait, on a trois étapes :
1, où est-ce qu'on a envie
d'aller, ensemble ;
2, comment va pouvoir y aller ensemble ;
3, eh ben, à trois on y va.
Donc, la première étape,
on va essayer de poser
une vision commune de notre avenir.
Elle ressemble à quoi
cette ville de demain
dans laquelle on a envie de vivre ?
Alors là, on a réuni une centaine
de personnes, de participants,
il y avait des citoyens,
simples habitants,
on avait avec nous des experts,
des acteurs publics et des acteurs privés.
Il y a des experts qui nous permettent
de donner du contexte,
ils nous apportent des connaissances,
quand on a besoin,
parce qu'on se pose des questions,
on n'a pas toujours des réponses.
Il y a des facilitateurs,
à toutes les étapes,
qui aident les gens à travailler.
Il y a un grand pilote
qui donne toutes les consignes,
parce qu'il y a
une méthode très structurée
qui permet d'arriver
à la fin avec du résultat.
Les gens aux tables, ils discutent,
ils dialoguent, ils débattent,
parfois ils ne sont pas d'accord,
mais on arrive toujours
à les mettre d'accord.
Et puis, ils produisent.
Au bout d'un moment,
on commence à avoir
cette vision qui prend forme,
qui devient visible
parce qu'elle est prototypée,
elle est maquettée,
elle est dessinée sur des grands posters
ou les gens racontent cette histoire,
et on les filme, il y a des scénarios,
ou il y a des maquettes.
On a même fait une expérience :
on a mis des écrans à toutes les tables
et ces écrans, ils nous permettaient
d'être en lien avec une communauté
de participants dématérialisés.
C''était des vrais gens
mais ils n'étaient pas avec nous.
Ils nous envoyaient
toutes leurs contributions
comme s'ils envoyaient des post-it
qui apparaissaient
comme ça sur les écrans.
Cela a très bien marché
parce qu'on a pu avoir une plus grande
communauté de participants.
À la fin, ces visions-là
nous ont montré que,
évidemment, la vision des citoyens
de la ville de demain
n'est pas celle des grandes firmes.
C'est une vision
qui est centrée sur l'humain,
une vision qui est intergénérationnelle,
une ville qui va être
plus à vélo qu'en voiture,
une ville où les voies d'eau redeviennent
des voies de transport,
c'est une ville où la nature
et l'urbanisation vivent en harmonie,
c'est une ville où le lien social
a une place absolument centrale,
c'est une ville où il fait bon vivre.
Finalement,
c'est une ville intelligente et vivante,
pas comme la ville chinoise.
Deuxième étape.
Maintenant qu'on a la vision,
on va regarder quelles sont les étapes
pour arriver à la concrétisation
de cette vision.
Sur le chemin,
on va rencontrer des obstacles,
des défis qu'il va falloir relever.
On va aussi avoir des soutiens
et on va avoir des ressources.
Le travail est le même,
on est avec les mêmes participants,
avec des gens qui vont les aider
à travailler ensemble
et le but du jeu est d'avoir à la fin
un cahier des charges
qui va nous permettre de faire
de la recherche de solutions.
Parmi les ressources qu'on va utiliser,
on va avoir des technologies,
des start-ups qui viennent nous aider,
on peut avoir des compétences,
des expertises, des gens qui viennent,
mais on a aussi des données :
la data, la fameuse data.
Alors la data, c'est quoi ?
Finalement, ce sont nos traces.
Partout on va, on passe,
nous avec nos téléphones, nos ordinateurs,
nos voitures, tous nos objets connectés,
nos montres maintenant,
bientôt nos chaussures,
partout on l'on passe,
on laisse des traces numériques.
Les organisations laissent des traces,
les objets connectés tout seuls
laissent des traces, d'ailleurs.
Donc, ces données-là sont dans une espèce
de grand nuage qu'on appelle le big data.
En fait, dans le big data,
on a des données qui sont confidentielles,
qui sont privées,
celles-là, on n'y touche pas.
Et il y a des données
qui sont ouvertes, publiques,
on l'appelle l'open data.
Nous on a pris l'open data et on l'a
donnée à réutiliser à nos participants
pour qu'ils puissent venir
à enrichir leurs ressources
et également leurs sources d'inspiration.
Troisième étape.
Les solutions.
Alors là, on va faire
un grand marathon de l'innovation
avec toujours les mêmes personnes
qu'on va aider, tout est structuré,
et à la fin de ces deux jours de marathon,
les gens auront produit des projets.
L'idée, c'est qu'ils fassent
prendre forme à des projets
qui leur permettent de concrétiser
la vision qu'ils ont eue au départ.
Ces projets vont prendre
la forme de prototypes, de maquettes,
qu'on va ensuite développer.
Comme on a embarqué
les parties prenantes dès le début,
les acteurs publics et privés,
les experts,
on va les développer plus facilement,
car tout le monde était là,
dès le départ, impliqué,
ils vont avoir envie
de développer les projets.
Ce qu'on a fait au niveau local,
on l'a aussi développé au niveau national,
sur le sujet du changement climatique.
Il a très bien marché que les ministères
se sont saisis du processus
et ils continuent l'expérience.
Comme quoi, les politiques
peuvent utiliser de nouveaux procédés.
J'ai envie de vous poser une question :
quel monde est-ce qu'on veut pour nous,
pour nos enfants et nos petits-enfants ?
Parce que ce qu'on a utilisé
au niveau local et au niveau national,
on peut l'utiliser
pour une nouvelle forme de démocratie.
En fait, la combinaison
de l'intelligence collective et du digital
peut nous permettre de créer
une démocratie directe et collaborative.
Pourquoi directe ?
Aujourd'hui, techniquement,
rien ne nous empêche
de pratiquer la démocratie directe.
On a déjà des plateformes
de démocratie participative
qui nous permettent de mettre en place
des budgets participatifs,
du vote en ligne,
on a des applications qui nous permettent
de faire des concertations en ligne,
on a tout ce qu'il faut.
Techniquement, c'est possible.
On a nos réseaux sociaux
qui permettent de faire des pétitions,
pas toujours écoutées.
On a des réseaux sociaux
qui nous permettent d'échanger,
de partager, de communiquer sur tout
ce qu'il se passe dans l'espace public.
Techniquement,
rien ne nous empêche, demain,
de créer une plate-forme digitale
où, avec des processus
d'intelligence collective,
on pourra poser
une vision d'ensemble des citoyens
qui viendront poser sur cette plateforme
leur vision de l'avenir,
un projet de société.
Également, tous les moyens de réaliser
ce projet de société,
un programme d'action.
C'est possible.
Ensuite, pour venir abonder
ces solutions, ces projets,
on pourra créer des lois,
proposer des lois,
c'est déjà possible aujourd'hui,
ensemble.
Voter ces lois et puis imaginer les moyens
de faire respecter ces lois par tous.
Aujourd'hui,
cette nouvelle forme de démocratie,
on l'a testée au plan local, ça marche.
On l'a testée au plan national, ça marche.
Et demain matin, on peut
très bien l'imaginer, au plan mondial.
Pourquoi pas ?
Vous voyez cette pierre ?
Finalement, nous citoyens,
on a notre futur entre nos mains.
On peut la construire, cette cathédrale.
Chacun emmène sa pierre et on peut bâtir
ce monde cathédrale dont on rêve.
Un monde où la technologie, le numérique
restent au service de l'humain.
Un monde où la diversité est protégée
et même encouragée.
Un monde où le lien social reste au centre
des préoccupations et de la vie.
Un monde où le bonheur redevient la quête,
pas seulement de chaque individu,
mais aussi du collectif.
Nous sommes
les futurs bâtisseurs du monde.
Moi, je le crois.
Une nouvelle citoyenneté,
une nouvelle démocratie sont possibles.
Maintenant, si vous le voulez bien,
j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse
une petite expérience.
J'aimerais bien qu'on se connecte
les uns aux autres.
Mais pas avec nos comptes Facebook,
nos téléphones,
j'aimerais bien
qu'on se connecte pour de vrai.
Je vais vous demander
de faire quelque chose :
est-ce que vous voulez bien
vous prendre les mains ?
Voulez-vous bien prendre la main
de votre voisin, de votre voisine ?
On se prend la main.
Génial !
Super !
Tout le monde a pris la main
de son voisin, de sa voisine ?
Voilà, on est connecté pour de vrai,
on est de vrais gens, on est connectés.
Il y en a qui n'ont pas de mains.
Maintenant qu'on est connectés,
on est ensemble,
comme ils disent les Africains,
j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse
un rêve ensemble.
J'aimerais bien qu'on imagine
le monde dans 15 ans.
On va fermer les yeux et
on va essayer de voir ce monde-là.
Je vais compter jusqu'à trois
et à trois, je vais vous demander
de fermer les yeux.
Un, deux, trois.
Alors, il est comment ce monde,
dont on rêve pour nous
et pour nos enfants ?
(Applaudissements)